la salida romper la nación a دبلوماسي
محور سياسي con el lugar de
peraleda مرحباً ، من يحتاج إلى ما يحدث في
فنزويلا هو أمر سريالي ،
فهو ليس فقط بلدًا به
اقتصاد منهار تضخم مفرط
ومشكلة أمنية خطيرة للغاية ولكن أيضًا
مع أزمة سياسية ودستورية الآن
تولى الرئيس نيكولاس مادورو
منصبه في العاشر من كانون الثاني (يناير) لكن أكثر من
اثنتي عشرة دولة في المنطقة بالإضافة
إلى الولايات المتحدة وكذلك الاتحاد الأوروبي
تقول إن حكومته غير
شرعية لأن انتخابات
العام الماضي كانت مزورة
بعد أن تولى مادورو منصبه.
الفوضى
كانت هناك انتفاضة صغيرة فاشلة
للجنود ضد الرئيس ، وكان هناك
أيضًا حكم من المحكمة العليا
يقول إن الجمعية الوطنية
بأكملها كانت غير شرعية
[موسيقى]
حرب قتل فيها 120 شخصًا على مدى عدة
أشهر من الاحتجاجات العنيفة في عام 2017
ويخشى البعض من أن التاريخ قد يعيد نفسه إلى
حد بعيد. فر أكثر من ثلاثة ملايين شخص من
فنزويلا في الزوجين الأخيرين  سنة
ومليون إضافي من المتوقع
أن يفعلوا نفس الشيء هذا